all right Colton what do you got for me
buddy yeah so uh Richard I've gone
through your book recently I was really
inspired by it uh the thing is that you
know uh I'm in my late 20s I'm 27 years
old or seven years old and I'm doing
very well financially uh so the thing is
that uh you know I'm I'm still facing an
issue even though you know I'm having uh
good money with me
um I'm having I think I have I don't
have a game as such and I'm really
worried while talking to women you know
if somebody I think is attractive I
can't really go and speak to her even
though the girl is giving me signal
skill I can't you know approach her
I live in India okay and you're having
issues making cold approaches yeah
and what are they doing when you
approach them
actually what has happened is you know
in the past I've received some bad
experiences I I would say uh the thing
is that you know a woman just you know
calling me creep or uh one time she just
hang on she called you a creep
yeah
um
uh because I asked her whether she would
like to go out and date with me and she
told me I'm older than you I didn't know
that actually and uh you know uh do you
think this is the right thing to do or
something I think you know culturally we
are very conservative Society you know
what do you do for a living bro you said
that you're well off yeah
multi-consultant I work in cyber
security
okay and
I don't know what the value is of your
income over there so why don't why don't
we do it this way like what in what
percentage of the income brackets are
you and like even the top one percent
top five percent top ten percent like
what are you earning I would say top uh
two percent in India so you're in the
top two percent of all income earners
and you're having women call you creeps
yeah that's that's really weird for me
uh all right I think I'm watching your
camera so we can get a look at you buddy
yeah it's actually early morning here
and I'm
wait a minute okay is because it's
because it's going to be something to do
with your approach it's not got to do
with your uh lifestyle
do you have a camera yeah
all right so you're so you're hitting
them up with
the look okay well you're not a bad
looking guy
but they're calling you creeps why like
what are you doing when you make the
approach
I I don't know I'm I'm doing something
wrong that's what I'm asking you know
that you know do you have anything that
I can go through which will improve my
game it's game it's game for you it's
game for you because I have another
friend uh I we just went to the Thailand
uh last month and where he was very
great with the woman but you know
eventually he couldn't get those two
girls uh there was Danish girls and I
ended up sleeping with a
vacation life is different than real
life back home when you walk out your
front door and you say hi to a girl that
you like right right it look I realize
it's first thing in the morning there's
probably something to do with style
maybe your hair can get cleaned up a
little bit you know sort of thing
um what I would do is grab
um I don't look I don't like to
recommend a lot of stuff when it comes
to uh gaming women but I would probably
go with Troy francis's stuff he's got
some he's got some good material you can
look up Renegade Playboy
he's got some book bundles right it's
going to work the same anywhere in the
world right
you can probably do something to improve
your look your hairstyle you know your
you know the clothes you're wearing you
say that you're making top two percent
as far as income goes and all I see
behind you is a door and a wall and some
curtains and a bunch of wires and you
don't look like you're living in a top
two percent of all income earners in
India to me
uh the thing is that we are actually
shifting somewhere else uh this is
something uh you know we are revamping
this this is a very old house of my
grandmothers I don't need an explanation
you've got a woman in the chat saying
fade your beard okay you know what a
fade is it's where it comes down and it
fades nicely
can you grow a full beard can you grow
full beard or is it just like that I I
don't think so I'm I'm almost 27 and
this is what I've all got right okay
well then maybe you're better off
without a beer like there's some guys
that shouldn't have facial hair all
right right so I mean like take a look
at Troy's stuff because he covers it
pretty much from most of the angles when
it comes to game
all right
try that okay yep thank you all right
buddy thanks hey guys I really hope that
you enjoyed that short clip if you did
consider supporting the creation of
content by checking out my supplement
line pinned in the top comment below of
this video in the comments there's a
link to the unpluggedalpha.com forward
slash shop when you click through you'll
be able to land over here and the entire
lineup is broken down by category that
it performs best in estrogen metabolism
fat burning your foundational Essentials
for health immune Health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code Alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the Subscribe and save
model or regular shipments will be sent
over to you on a regular basis and that
gives you a little bit of a discount and
your supplement facts are always broken
down over here thanks for watching I
hope you guys have an awesome day and
again check out that link it's pinned in
the top comment below in this video
peace out